[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
[Music]
all right and we are live more incognito
ireland podcast launching gaming.net and
who are these fine people we have in the
realm of play nyc what's going on here
hello we are batsu about to the
punishment card game the punishment card
game yes
yes watson means punishment or penalty
in japanese you ever hear the show's
silent library yes uh so basically it's
silent library uh we have a east village
show
that we've done for about 10 years now
and obviously with the pandemic things
have slowed down so we've made a card
game version oh
kind of like cards against humanity
where there's one judge and everyone
does a challenge okay but instead of the
judge picking a winner they pick whoever
did
the least
funny thing oh so who was the worst
whoever was the worst
or a punishment so so tell us about the
batsu and why is there a chicken on the
bottom what's going on
this is mr chicken he's about to make an
appearance right now he is one of our
botsu's there he is actually a kid the
infamous mr chicken this is the rise the
infamous mr chicken yes right so he's
used
mechanics he's one of the punishments he
drops eggs on people's heads
hey
and he steals things from you and he
steals he steals as well yeah yeah
but uh mr chicken here he drops eggs on
people's heads at our show and he is one
of our mascots the mascot yeah now you
mentioned two things you said it it
transformed batsu from something from
from a gamepad standpoint to a card game
yeah okay so what what about the initial
vision yeah what can you tell us about
that before transforming yeah so uh the
live show was in east village uh we did
seven shows a week and basically it's uh
four improvisers coming out they do
different improv challenges this is
improv too oh that's cool
and if they don't make the audience
laugh or if they fail a challenge they
receive a botsu absolutely noriko here
and then she comes out noriko comes out
and then she she punishes them not with
this but
that's violence i strike the gun right
there okay i strike
[Music]
[Music]
she'll shoot them with a paintball gun
it's a it's a pretty crazy show and we
have the new york location we have a
chicago location as well and
yeah yeah it's pretty awesome it's very
awesome i'm glad we stopped by this is
the most entertaining booth y'all bought
two so again so for people who want to
know about boxing yeah where do they go
where can they find where can they get
the game what can they do absolutely
uh and you can go to batsu live.com or
googlebotsu and uh you can find our card
game and we should be coming back in
september or so for the live show for
the live show so uh come to the east
village company chicago so we got all
right give us the location east village
yeah east village it's gonna be on
fourth street and first avenue it's a
batu all you have to do is google watson
you'll find us and now what about my
chicago lords that's in the chicago area
yeah absolutely so we're in old town at
this uh beautiful japanese restaurant
called kamehachi oh nice nice
this is awesome vlatsu you heard it here
first don't get punished don't get the
bomb don't get the chicken
[Laughter]
salute to you guys you guys are awesome
thank you so much i love podcasts
has the latest booth in this whole thing
i had to salute them
please
[Music]
you